avril c'est le printemps ici le
renouveau la nature qui reprend ses
droits
mais pour aimer munezero née au rwanda
avril évoque la douleur
arrivé au canada en 2014 en passant
d'abord par la belgique
elle n'avait pour tout bagage que les
photos de mariage de ses parents m c'est
ma tante may permettre la sorte dans ma
mère l'aurait strict massacre des photos
qui témoignent de tous les disparus dans
la famille
bon il ma cousine ont demandé à maman ça
c'est qui dsa ces thèmes il est têtu et
ça c'est un fait mais les mois sur la
photo avec 70 personnes plus une et je
crois qu'ils en avaient une dizaine qui
qu'ils étaient vivants qu'ils étaient
vivants
sur les soixante dix où des 2 7 avril
1994 c'est le début du génocide
sa famille a fui et se réfugie chez des
parents au sud du pays
elle a quatre ans mon père est parti à
matin pour aller chercher de palinges me
chercher à manger un héros
[Musique]
le saurai jamais je sais qu'il est mort
et pendant très longtemps en étant
enfant je pensais qu'il allait revenir
ma grand mère maternelle la seule image
kg d'elle c'est son crâne
son crâne ouvert avant de la tuer elle
avait demandé à prier pour ses enfants
et 1 donc on l'a retrouvée avec son
chapelet lorsque aimé est arrivé au
québec il ya quatre ans elle voulait
fuir ce passé et cette violence
incompréhensible
quand je suis arrivé au québec je me
suis dit c'est un nouveau départ vous
savez pas ce n'est pas parce que je vais
passer vous rattrape le passé où ils
proviennent les cauchemars où viennent
les bruits les odeurs
il est quelqu'un qui vienne tuer c'est
horrible mais ça oui c'est incontrôlable
ça peut venir en deux secondes et mais
essaie encore de comprendre ce massacre
qui a fait huit cent mille morts en
trois mois selon l'onu
j'ai un besoin de lire de reprendre sa
venue j'ouvris fallait avez vous compris
encore et je comprendrais jamais loges
bouderra est arrivé au canada en 2002 il
avait 18 ans après des études en droit à
montréal il a fondé une famille et
travaille aujourd'hui à ottawa pour le
gouvernement fédéral
on pourrait croire que tout va pour le
mieux mais lui aussi est rattrapé par
son passé
7 avril 1994 est une date marquante dans
sa vie il avait dix ans les gens qui
étaient décapités qui était physique et
qui tombé dans la rivière niaba longo
les gens qui avaient été blessés sur
tous les endroits de leur corps et qui
essayait de rester en vie en cachette
avec moi quelques jours plus tard son
père médecin est arrêté et exécuté le
reste de la famille est recueilli par
une de ses tantes tout sic marié 1 où
tous les gens qui nous cacher il pouvait
faire ça parce qu'il était exemplaire
entre et d'exécuter les autres ils
resteront là pendant plus de trois mois
on était cachée dans une famille photos
qui avaient des frères et soeurs sur les
barrières anti rentrée de tuer de tout
qui revenait la nuit qui revenait à midi
pour ce déjeuner qui revenait la nuit
pour 10 mai et qui racontait tout ce
qu'ils avaient fait durant la journée
qui était que d'aller chercher tuer les
tutsis ce qui frappe loges bouderra
encore aujourd'hui c'est cette banalité
du mal c'est les gens n'auront qui prime
avant leur combiné mais après leur
prière après que le nombre pas comment
ce qui décrit des scènes horribles de
massacre et du génocide qui arrive
devant la porte
une bonne partie de sa famille a été
décimée ma grammaire surtout qui fut
exécuté j'étais dans une fosse commune
où elle est restée vivante pendant trois
jours
dès mes tantes à moi mes oncles leurs
enfants à quelques dizaines à peu près
70 personnes il ya des cous et à nous de
famille de 12 personnes et sert aux
personnes qui restent qui porte leur nom
après cette folie meurtrière sa mère est
toujours vivante
mais sa survie tient du miracle elle a
été amenée aux fosses communes pour être
exécuté au moins dix fois et chacun de
ces risques d'exécution finissez par une
confusion quelqu'un qui prend pitié
d'elle des miracles allemand parce que
le dernier jour de personnes qui étaient
envoyés pour lui à qui tu étais un
ancien patient de mon père qui avait
reconnu la faute de notre famille
lorsqu'il avait apporté dans notre
maison pour l'exécuter là bas et qui a
décidé d'aller dire à ses collègues que
lt morte aujourd'hui après 25 ans il y a
encore des odeurs qui le ramène en
arrière
l'odeur du sang c'est c'est quelque
chose de très distincts il y avait
beaucoup de morts qui n'était pas
enterrée de fort qui se décomposait
alors on est végétarien mais l'odeur de
la viande qui se décompose jeu c'est
énervant je le sais que mon corps en
réelle vie avril est à moi triste et
pénible pour les rwandais qui ont vécu
le génocide
on a prayer qui dit que dieu passe la
journée ailleurs il revient le soir il
dort le soir ils disaient que ce soir là
ce soir là tu n'es pas arrivé
pleurer si je pleure je m'arrêterai pas
qui le comprends je ne sais pas il faut
qu'on en parle
[Musique]